hello everyone and welcome to another
Bitcoin video this video is going to be
covering an issue that's been in the
news quite a bit but it's very much in
the spotlight right now in New York with
these Bitcoin hearings also I'll just go
ahead and mention that most of my
examples and facts here are going to be
based on the United States rules and
regulations in place but most of the
supplies pretty much anywhere so the
question is should we regulate Bitcoin
if so how hot we go about doing that now
immediately I think there should be a
distinction between regulation and
legislation Bitcoin definitely needs
some legislation regarding how it can
operate alongside the dollar but should
it be regulated right should Bitcoin
itself be regulated or maybe better put
showed the interaction between the
Bitcoin in the US dollar be regulated so
oftentimes in the world of politics any
sort of need for a reason to infringe on
rights usually falls under one of two
catchers when it comes to general human
rights violations it's usually a matter
of national security or terrorism or
anything like that that way rights can
be infringed upon in the case of
businesses a popular catch-all is anti
money laundering and just outright
criminal activity here naturally the
banking system we have today or even you
know Wall Street in general you know
we've got giant book after book of rules
and regulation and these have totally
eradicated all crime so yeah that aside
the allegation that criminal activity is
quite uncle easy let's say with Bitcoin
but the allegation is that criminal
activity is easy with Bitcoin and it
should be regulated so first we should
consider you know where does Bitcoin
stand right now because some people give
the notion that bitcoin is like this
totally free currency um if you read the
media it's an actual physical coin you
can do anything you want with it you can
buy drugs still you can put hits on
people's lives basically whatever you
want to do with this coin as it stands
right now under current regulation and
laws and all of this if you profit in
dollars on your Bitcoin you Oh what
capital gains
tax on it obviously if you profit pure
Bitcoin you don't know cap gains on that
so if you're investing in Bitcoin you
owe your taxes on any realized gains so
when you convert you know your Bitcoin
in at coinbase into dollars you have to
pay your taxes there that's already in
place you already have to do this if you
transact goods or services as a business
in Bitcoin and later convert to dollars
you owe your typical business taxes on
Bitcoin or on that Bitcoin transaction
rather if you do a point-of-sale
conversion on Bitcoin yo your typical
business taxes that's already in place
it's still illegal to buy cocaine with
Bitcoin in the United States already in
place if you wish to operate in exchange
from Bitcoin the US dollar or most
dollars you still must get the proper
paperwork done and acquire the necessary
licenses as any exchange would already
in place already have the licenses ready
to go everything's there when you buy
and sell things with Bitcoin everything
you do is track down a one hundred
percent public ledger that everyone has
access to and they can view your full
history account value transactions all
this done that's already there criminals
like Dread Pirate Roberts who have run
drug rings like Silk Road have been
traced tracked and brought to justice by
the FBI criminals running Ponzi schemes
like pirate at 40 they've been found
successfully and prosecuted by the SEC
despite the notion that bitcoin is
totally anonymous it actually is more
revealing than transacting in cash
here's an excerpt straight from SEC gov
after pirate at 40 fraudsters are not
beyond the reach of the SEC just because
they use Bitcoin or another virtual
currency to mislead investors and
violate the federal securities laws and
Andrew am kalam set out Andrew M
calamari director of the SCC's New York
Regional Office shavers preyed on
investors in an online forum by claiming
his investments carried no risk and huge
profits for them while his true
intentions were rooted in nothing more
than personal greed this straight from
the SEC man so as you can see here this
is just one example of how existing
rules and regulations are all ready in
place to manage true Bitcoin criminal
activity there's no need for more
Bitcoin regulation to protect against
crime
is already here and the only like the
place for actual money laundering to
occur is in the exchanges guess what the
exchanges are regulated now while we're
on the topic of pirate at 40 further he
ran a fake investment fund of sorts
where he promised investors one percent
gain a day now investors had to trust
him they gave him their Bitcoin and when
you invest in a mutual fund today it's
the same thing you can view your account
value so to speak but you don't actually
own that money it's more of like a
representation of your value and this
really the same with most funds now take
a fund like mine for example I'm able to
run my fund right now without any
regulation the following way or without
any more regulation I still can't you
know defraud anybody I can still be
prosecuted by the ICC they can still
audit me all this stuff anyway one I
don't need your name your address your
social security number your tax ID
driver's license number photo ID
employee ID number none of that I don't
need it because it's not necessary I
don't need your Bitcoin I asked for a
deposit to protect myself but ninety
percent of your Bitcoin stays in your
account three I don't need your account
info trading is done in your account
this is incredibly important for
transparency and security right every
investor can see the trades act of real
trades actually taking place in their
account and not just have to trust that
there's no you know no scheme going on
plus they retain control so they suspect
something was indeed awry next trades
are done via the API doesn't allow for
withdrawals people's money like is their
money they don't have to entrust their
money right this is the right way to do
it it's great you don't see this option
in the real world of Wall Street why
mostly because of regulation
requirements right scams and schemes are
still incredibly crazy and rampant uh
let's look at a scam that is regulated
binary options sorry I don't mean to
offend people who are like fans of
binary options I've haven't spoken to
anybody well I guess I've met a few
people that that didn't think it was
gambling but it look based on the rules
of math it's gambling right the
regulation
they even regulate gambling right in a
lot of places allowed now regulation
doesn't stop crime schemes scams all
this right and I'm gonna for the right
to gamble it doesn't mean you should but
you should have the right regulation of
it is just the feds sticking their hands
in the pot right so when are the current
settings people are able to run not only
funds but businesses can be also run in
these extremely transparent ways like my
fund is run ways we've never even been
able to see before right so like let's
for example like businesses side how
about charities how many charities have
turned out to be just total scams right
and these guys are regulated to I
remember watching that like a news
segment where they went around
researching all these charities for
veterans and like two and a ten we're
actually using the money correctly and
this required a lot of digging a lot of
Investigation a lot of work with Bitcoin
if you have a Bitcoin charity you can
track their addresses literally and see
where the money goes transparency
bitcoins not this dirty anonymous scheme
that people think it is nor does it
require any further regulation if
anything regulation is going to hinder
the free ability to people run a
business the right way now take me for
example look I'm all for SEC regulations
I'm all for the SEC smacking up pirate
at 40 putting him in jail prison
whatever otherwise um you know other
scum anybody I'm all for that right
that's fine if the SEC wants to see my
records and my transaction that's fun
i'm going to be totally compliant with
them i'm still required to report
suspicious activity and in fact that's
exactly what charlie shrem CEO of
bitinstant is in jail for and he's there
for not reporting suspicious activity
with regards to Silk Road accounts these
these rules and regulations already in
place law enforcement can already do
what they need to do but sure as long as
you've got testimony coming from the
Winklevoss twins who desperately want to
get regulations so that they can go
forward with their Bitcoin ETF it'll
seem like regulations a good idea so
anyway that's going to conclude my
should we really regulate Bitcoin video
if you have any counter arguments or
comments feel free to leave them below
as always thanks for watching things for
all of the support in this obscure
options and until next time